في تطور غير مسبوق اسرائيليا اصبح التهديد
واقعا حيث لم يلتحق 180 طيارا حربيا
وملاحا جويا من الاحتياط والعشرات من
مشغلي المسيرات والعاملين في مجال السايبر
بوحداتهم وانضموا الى بدء 650 من مقاتلي
الوحدات الخاصه السريه من الاحتياط
عصيانهم العسكري ايضا احتجاجا على ما بات
يسمى بمحاوله انقلاب الحكومه على نظام
القضاء في اسرائيل
وقاده الاجهزه الامنيه التصدي بحزم لرفض
الخدمه العسكريه ليس هناك مكان للاسيان
العسكري في السجال العام دوله ترغب في
البقاء لا يمكنها التسليم بظواهر كهذه
ظاهره رفض الخدمه في صفوف قوات الاحتياط
التي تشكل عماد الجيش الاسرائيلي ونصف
القوه العملانيه لسلاح الجو مرشحه للاتساع
في ظل استمرار تظاهرات الاحتجاج الحاشده
واصرار الحكومه على المضيف خطه تغيير نظام
القضاء واضعاف المحكمه العليا وسط تحضيرات
متواتره من ان تقود بوادر العنف الى حرب
اهليه
كما دوما فاننا امام امكاني تدهور امني
على عده جبهات وممنوع علينا ان تدور حرب
اخوه على جبهتنا الداخليه نتنياهو توقف
على الاقل الى ما بعد شهر رمضان
الخشيه لدى القياده العسكريه والامنيه من
ان يؤدي وصول الانقسام الى صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى انهيار موقع لجماع شبه
الوحيد في المجتمع الاسرائيلي وان تتراجع
معنويات القتال فيما تنتظر اسرائيل تحديات
خارجيه فايران تلامس القدره النوويه
العسكريه وحزب الله اختبر اسرائيل في
عمليه مجدو في العمق وثم التخوف من اندلاع
حرب جديده على قطاع غزه وانفجار الوضع في
الضفه في شهر رمضان المغترب
بعد ان وصل الانقسام في الشارع الاسرائيلي
الى صفوف الجيش من خلال موجه رفض الخدمه
من قبل نخب قتاليه في الاحتياط يرى
مراقبون بان ذلك سيمس بجاهزيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي القتاليه في مواجهه تحديات
قريبه وبعيده وقد يؤدي الى اختبار جهات
خارجيه للواقع الاسرائيلي المازوم عسكريا
وهو يقرا ضعفا ووهنا زياد حلبي العربيه
القدس الغربيه